suit notre second débat débat de société
débat prospectif vous le savez on
choisit de consacrer cette dernière
partie d'émission un débat
volontairement décalée de l'actualité du
jour et on passe souvent au crible les
propositions des candidats ce soir
que qu'invente il que promet-il à une
jeunesse française qui votent de moins
en moins pour commencer on va dresser le
bilan des manuels macron qui est le plus
jeune président de l'histoire de la vème
république hugo lemonnier le jour de son
élection il n'a pas quarante ans mais à
peine élu emmanuel macron doit faire
face à un mouvement de contestation de
la jeunesse en cause la baisse de 5
euros des apl attente on voit
aujourd'hui la part du budget points
un couple une personne seule avec ou
sans enfants que ça représente les
logements c'est clair non seulement ça
va pas dans le bon sens mais c'est
véritablement scandaleux une économie
mensuelle de 32,5 millions d'euros pour
l'état et une faute politique pour le
président de la république je sais les 5
euros d'apl je le traîne comme un boulet
alors que c'était une décision avant que
le gouvernement a prises dès le premier
dès le premier était ça faisait pas
partie de mes engagements j'assume quand
je peux que des décisions difficiles que
sonic est je me suis engagé la crise du
coc vide va offrir au gouvernement une
chance de renouer avec la jeunesse à la
rentrée 2020 les files s'allongent
devant les distributions alimentaires
des jeunes qui vivait de petits boulots
et que les confinements successifs ont
plongé dans la grande pauvreté enfin il
ya plus de job étudiant chinois tchéquie
tu postules tu peux passer ta jeune et
impressionné des fois par une patte de
réponse avec la situation force le
gouvernement à prendre des mesures en
urgence repas 1 euro pour tous les
étudiants aide exceptionnelle de 150
euros pour les bénéficiaires d'apl où le
système un jeune une solution dont
emmanuel macron a encore vanté les
mérites lors de sa dernière allocution
nous avons aidé 3 millions de jeunes à
trouver une formation ou un emploi ou un
accompagnement ce qui fait qu'au moment
où je vous parle le taux de chômage pour
les jeunes est au plus bas depuis plus
de 15 certes au plus bas le taux de
chômage des moins de 25 ans avoisine
toujours les 20% le gouvernement mise
donc sur une dernière mesure le contrat
d'engagement jeunes un contrat et non un
revenu parce qu'au droit que nous
ouvrons à savoir 20 heures de suivi
intensif une allocation pouvant aller
jusqu'à 500 euros correspondent des
devoirs de voir d'assiduité devoir de
suivre les formations proposées et de
s'engager pleinement un dispositif qui
existait déjà sous un autre nom c'est la
philosophie de la garantie jeunes qui a
été créée il ya maintenant six ans où
s'étend à qui s'adressait à des jeunes
avec
un volontarisme très fort de la part des
missions locales qui avaient été
alimentées en moyens humains pour
pouvoir assurer un suivi de qualité
pendant un an et en direction de chaque
jeune là ce que j'ai peur c'est qu'on
aboutisse à une forme de braderie de la
garantie jeunes au profit du contrat
d'engagement et on va afficher quatre
cent mille jeunes suivis alors qu'il en
faudrait au moins deux fois plus à cinq
mois des présidentielles la majorité se
lance dans la campagne avec un nouveau
slogan macron président des jeunes avec
un espoir renouvelé l'exploit de 2010
est une élection plus de 60 % des moins
de 25 ans avait voté emmanuel macro
second tour
les jeunes sont-ils les oubliés de cette
campagne présidentielle on en débat tout
de suite avec mes invités mélanie vogel
bonjour bienvenue soit vous êtes
sénatrice europe ecologie les verts
représentant les français établis hors
de france anne muxel bonsoir bien mieux
vaut aussi sociologues politologues et
reese recherche en sociologie et science
politique au cevipof vous publiez
politiquement jeunes c'est aux éditions
de l'aube frédéric dabi bonsoir frédéric
directeur général opinions du groupe
ifop
vous publiez avec et stewart show la
fracture c'est aux éditions les arènes
en duplex avec nous alexandre mans sino
qui est avocat président du cercle
aurions cofondateur d'un pacte bonsoir
et bienvenue à vous aussi matthieu
croissandeau toujours à mes côtés
évidemment bonsoir mathieu on reviendra
sur le bilan des manuels macron ce sera
l'un des thèmes de nos débats mais je
voudrais d'abord frédéric dabi commencer
par ce sondage que vous avez réalisé
publia une semaine sur les intentions de
vote et la mobilisation des jeunes 42%
des jeunes sont sûrs d'aller voter sont
sûrs c'est-à-dire que sur une la
question de 1 à 10 6 17e vis chez des
principes nationaux sûrs d'aller voter
42% et puis ensuite on a les intentions
de vote de ce qui était qui était sondés
videmment marine le pen arrivait en tête
25 % emmanuel macron 19% yannick jadot
14% je signale que c'était il ya une
semaine donc avant la désignation de
valérie pécresse c'est vrai que tu es
fait léviter remis environ un mois des
voilà donc moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
ce premier chiffre que le chiffre de
l'abstention des moins de 30 ans est ce
qu'elle est beaucoup plus forte que la
moyenne des ja oui oui oui à le volt et
l'absence ou toujours indexé sur l'âge
on est plus jeune qui vote le moins mais
pas à l'élection présidentielle vous un
sentiment si tu es mon livre et je
reviens sur l'histoire de l'élection
présidentielle auprès des jeunes et il
ya eu des élections 80 surtout 95 et
demi c'est donc des élections de rupture
où les jeunes ont vraiment vu un enjeu
aller voter où l'abstention a été quasi
équivalente entre les moins de 24 ans
les primo votants c'est 18 22 pour être
plus précis celle qui vote pour la
première fois à une élection
présidentielle et le reste des français
mais c'est vrai que au delà de cette
spécificité de l'élection présidentielle
en enquête réalisée pour ce livre on a
deux tiers des jeunes qui disent que la
présidentielle est une chance pour la
france pour autant il ya un contexte
très compliqué une abstention massive
ainsi quatre solistes jamais vu dans le
pays puisque depuis le début du
quinquennat à toutes les élections un
point d'écart aux élections européennes
mais l'abstention a été majoritaire à
chaque scrutin et donc une seule
abstention du côté des jeunes c'était je
crois 84% élections régionales 66 au
niveau national et 84 87 concert pour
les jeunes et dans ces zones à douter
des chiffres absolument et il ne faut
pas mais 6 mai par l'importance du
scrutin présidentiel et le fait que je
réponds peut-être directement à votre
question les politiques je trouve essaye
de s'adresser beaucoup aux jeunes et des
canaux jeunes et vient des mesures
jeunes alors justement mélanie volée ça
ça dépend des candidats comment redonner
aux jeunes l'envi de se rendre dans
l'isoloir pour cette présidentielle ça
dépend d'abord des candidats de leur
programme de leur faculté à je sais pas
si il faut employer le terme du de de
rêve de d'espoir alors évidemment et je
pense qu'elle est bien sûr il ya une
partie qui dépendent des candidats de ce
qu'on défile apprend à parler du vote à
16 ans et ses techniques mais est-ce que
ça dépend d'abord des programmes et de
cela dépend bien sûr de la capacité
qu'on a à parler à cette génération est
la capacité qu'ont à répondre aux
questions qu'elle se pose il ya de plus
en plus de jeunes qui déclarent être ce
qu'on appelle échos anxieux c'est à dire
qu'ils sont
angoissés par la perspective du
changement climatique parce qu'ils sont
nés avec cette idée que l'humanité
allait peut-être disparaître ce qui est
moi je suis pas très bien mais c'est
quand même pas mon cas je suis pas né
avec mes parents qui me disait tu sais
peut-être que me délecter n'existera
plus donc c'est sûr que il ya cette
question qui est ce qu'on est capable de
répondre à leurs questions après et on y
viendra peut-être peut-être plus tard
mais je pense qu'il ya aussi globalement
l'état du débat public est ce que les
institutions françaises sont capables de
créer des réponses ou plutôt de la
frustration est ce que tout allait bien
on fait de la politique en france ça
montre aux gens qu'en fait ça sert à
quelque chose de voter et de s'engager
ouais
un must-have sur cette question sur le
levier effectivement est-ce que ça va
jusqu'à une réforme institutionnelle et
levier pour restaurer la confiance des
jeunes envers la les politiques en
général oui la restaurer la confiance
vous avez raison de de dire cela ça ne
concerne pas que les jeunes la défiance
envers les institutions et le personnel
politique dans le pays et considération
je suis ensemble de la population donc
pas étonnant finalement que que les
jeunes dont les parents les grands
parents dans l'ensemble effectivement
des des personnes auxquelles ils sont
confrontés bien partage aussi cet cette
défiance alors je crois qu'effectivement
les personnes les personnalités les
responsables politiques
capable d'incarner un à la fois les
espoirs des jeunes mais aussi les enjeux
qui peuvent les mobiliser c'est
important mais il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
non plus que ça je crois que la question
des programmes la question des
propositions la question aussi de
de donner une possibilité de se projeter
dans un monde en profonde mutation a
manqué les angoisses énormément c'était
comment accepter effectivement très
importante chez les jeunes une
difficulté à anticiper ce qu'est ce que
sera le futur et la société telle
qu'elle doit être pour aller vers ce
futur ça je crois que c'est vraiment la
feuille de route des politiques mais
alexandre lancino c'est à la fois une
anxiété et est un défi on peut aussi
positiver la démonstration un défi
fabuleux a relevé il ya peut-être pas eu
de
défi aussi important pour une génération
depuis depuis je ne sais pas plus d'un
siècle qu'est ce que vous lisez aussi ce
contexte comme cela
vous évite tout à fait autre chose qui
ait plusieurs choses je pense
qu'effectivement le politique qui a une
vraie vision fin de se doit d'avoir une
révision est une vraie responsabilité
effectivement pour pour proposer une
vision de la société et pour parvenir à
rassembler le plus de jeunes possible
autour de sa vision qu'il a du pays non
ça c'est un premier point le deuxième
point c'est que on a parlé des
institutions je pense qu'effectivement
au regard aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de politiques publiques mériterait
peut-être d'être mis sur les tables pour
par exemple inciter les plus jeunes
d'entre nous a voté par exemple sur leur
campus d'études on sait à quel point en
parfois il est difficile pour des jeunes
de de ça 2 aurait inscrire sur des
listes électorales dès lors qu il quitte
le domicile parental c'est un deuxième
point le troisième point me semble-t-il
c'est la responsabilité de l'école
notamment de l'école dans dans sa dans
la responsabilité de nos politiques
publiques et l'éducation nationale a
sensibilisé des plus jeune âge aux
enjeux de la citoyenneté aux enjeux les
citoyennetés doute que nous proposons
juge président du cercle orient qui
tentent d'en qui rassemble toute une
jeunesse autour des grands enjeux de
société et sous nous proposons c'est par
exemple dès le plus jeune âge avoir des
enseignements à l'éducation civique des
enseignements sur l'histoire pour
s'assimiler l'histoire de france et pour
être en mesure d plus jeune âge une dès
l'entrée au collège par exemple eh bien
d'abord c'est de cette sensibilisation l
histoire allant de nérac l'instant
mathieu ça vous fait réagir jour donne
la parole d'autrui je pense qu'on peut
faire porter beaucoup de choses à
l'école l'éducation nationale mais c'est
aussi culturelle et sociétale et il ya
des cours d'instruction civique alors
peut-être que on peut faire plus il ya
des cours d'histoire ça existe déjà il
ya une sensibilisation à faire au niveau
au niveau des familles et il s'agit pas
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
exclusif c'est là il faut réenchanter la
politique pour tout le monde il faut pas
commencer à s'alimenter à marcq était à
faire mesures spéciales jeu alors après
est-ce qu'on peut rapprocher facilité
inscriptions chez listes électorales oui
faciliter le vote des jeunes repenser
est-ce qu'on peut voter de façon
numérique ou non pourquoi pas il y at il
un débat mené sur l'âge de vote
sans doute va-t-il sourire mais mais je
pense pas que ce soit forcément à
l'école de tout faire elle a déjà
beaucoup de choses à faire comme ça
faut-il avancer le droit de vote à l'âge
de 16 ans proposition de la candidate
socialiste anne hidalgo on écoute anne
hidalgo c'était le 25 encore octobre
dernier chez nos confrères de france
info
droit de vote à 16 ans parce que je
crois qu'on ne peut pas continuer à
prendre des décisions aujourd'hui l'âme
et qui impacte notre futur à et quand
emmanuel contraire qu'il fallait faire
plein de petites centrales nucléaires
partout je suis désolé les jeunes de 16
ans ils doivent pouvoir se prononcer là
dessus parce que c'est leur avenir et
j'appelle quant à calmer à nous
rejoindre bonsoir quentin venez venez
parce que les sénateurs socialistes dans
la foulée de ce que vient de dire anne
hidalgo propose d'inscrire dans la loi
l'une de ces propositions le veau droit
de vote à 16 ans ça ça arrive là dans le
calendrier du sénat exactement demain à
l'ordre du jour tout à fait thomas vous
êtes bien renseigné et en fait la vraie
question les socialistes c'est comment
amener les jeunes vers la citoyenneté et
c'est ce qui se demandent en fait avec
cette proposition de loi le point de
départ ce sont les mauvais chiffres de
la participation aux élections va revoir
ceux des dernières élections ce sont les
régionales et départementales avec des
chiffres particulièrement faible on le
voit seuls 17 % des 18-24 ans qui vote à
ce scrutin 19 % pour les 25-34 ans quand
on le voit la moyenne elle est plutôt
autour de 34% et pour les chercheurs
auditionné par les socialistes les
études démontrent que plus on apprend à
voter tôt plus on vote et plus on est un
électeur fidèles thomas est donc au-delà
de l'abaissement du seuil d'âge de 18 à
16 ans cette proposition de loi débattue
demain au sénat elle vise à mieux
accompagner le vote chez les jeunes avec
quelques mesures comme des cours de
sciences politiques dès le collège mais
aussi la formation un davantage
d'informations pour les enseignants afin
qu'ils puissent comme cela aussi est
guidé leurs élèves et enfin on voit la
création de conseils de jeunes dans
toutes les communes de plus de 5000
habitants le texte est donc examiné en
séance demain mais il ne devrait pas
être adopté pour quoi et bien parce que
la droite n'est pas favorable à ce
rabaissement de 18 à 16 ans pour le
droit de vote regardez ce qu'a dit un
sénateur et leur site et sur
publicsenat.fr c'est olivier paccaud il
dit permettra un adolescent de prendre
part aux élections alors même qu'il ait
reconnu largement irresponsables par le
droit français serait source de
confusion alors qu'en pense de son côté
le gouvernement on a posé la question à
la secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et à
l'engagement c'est sarah est là est
restée à quelques jours sur notre
plateau vous allez voir elle se mouille
pas beaucoup
j'ai pas de j'ai pas eu de demande très
spécifiques des jeunes que je croise en
dehors des associations allée qui
évidemment je consulte avec qui je
travaille qui me disent la réponse à
l'abstention c'est là droits de vote et
au droit de vote à 16 ans je ne suis pas
opposé je ne suis pas favorable je pense
que ça lui est arrivé mardi
ça veut dire ne pas se mouiller donc ces
suppressions suite des débats demain 16h
au sénat tous merci beaucoup merci quand
un pur pour ces détails mélanie vogel
vous y est favorable ce droit de vote à
16 ans alors nous ça fait longtemps les
écologistes que nous proposons le droit
de vote à 16 ans donc nous y sommes
favorables nous voterons la proposition
de loi demain maintenant je vais être
très franche et très honnête je ne crois
pas que ce soit l'alpha et l'oméga de
réponse à l'abstention des jeunes
c'est pas c'est bien comme ça a été dit
on sait les études montrent que plus on
s'engage tôt plus on a de chance de
rester dans le circuit démocratique
maintenant je pense que la crise cette
drôle aussi pardon de vous interrompre
mais c'est ce que ce que disait quand on
cherche à fidéliser dans sa famille
politique ça fait penser aux banques qui
essaye de capter les les jeunes diplômés
pour les garder le plus longtemps
possible voici un petit peu non mais a
précédé des scientifiques qui disent ah
oui monsieur law qui disent assez haut
ce qu'on constate c'est qu'il ya un
apprentissage de la démocratie et que
quand on a été éduquée est habitué à
participer à voter on a tendance à ne
pas cesser de le faire fin on a moins de
tendance a commencé de le faire
mais je suis parfaitement réaliste sur
cette question je ne crois pas que ça va
répondre et d'ailleurs on voit en
autriche à malte dans les états qui
l'ont mis en place bon ça a fait une
beauté des gens c'est quand même un big
7 millions de jeunes qui seraient
concernés après tendanciellement c'est
pas ça je pense que la réponse elle est
beaucoup plus globale pardon mais il n'y
a pas de souci je vais je par frédéric
pas ce qu'il ya dans vos enquêtes c'est
intéressant de voir comment les jeunes
réagissent à cette proposition d anne
muxel est ce que c'est pour vous l'une
des rares mesures un peu phare un peu
marquante dans ce début de campagne
présidentielle à destination des jeunes
cette proposition d'anne hidalgo on
parle beaucoup en tout cas certains
candidats et candidates se sont saisies
effectivement cet enjeu pour voilà pour
être visible non seulement au sein de la
population mais aussi tout
particulièrement en direction en
direction des jeunes moi je partage ce
qui a été dit ce n'est pas une réponse à
l'abstention puisque l'abstention de
toutes les façons touche toutes les
classes les classes d'âge d'ailleurs il
faudrait s'intéresser à l'abstention de
la fin de l'échelle des âges qui est
quand même très importante n'oublions
pas que la participation c'est une une
courbe en u avec effectivement là où les
moments où on participe le moins
électoralement c'est au début
effectivement de la vie de citoyens et à
la fin à la fin de
cette ville de cette même ville donc
voilà il faudrait effectivement on
aurait une une réflexion plus générale
par ailleurs il est vrai aussi que
le vote c'est la signification de l'acte
de voter s'est profondément modifié
aussi aujourd'hui les électeurs sont des
électeurs intermittents et l'abstention
peut être utilisée par eux aussi comme
comme un moyen d'expression politique
pourrait forme de protestation ciment
pour exprimer un désaccord vis-à-vis de
l'offre électorale pour marquer une
sanction à l'encontre des gouvernements
donc en fait je crois que il ya
nécessité de penser ce rapport veulent
dans un dans cette panoplie c'était
largy des outils à la disposition des
citoyens aujourd'hui pour s'exprimer
dans nos démocraties famille est ce que
c'est une demande de la jeunesse ou
alors tout simplement un bon marqueur de
gauche pour anne hidalgo en watts un
service a peut être une mesure à
audition de la peine de mort une mesure
symbolique forme mais un ce n'est pas
une demande de la jeunesse et de l'ours
que très récemment mois des élections
régionales pour l'association l'anacej
qu'il faille qui essayent de favoriser
la participation des jeunes à des
conseils municipaux des conseils de
quartier il ya un rejet ya un refus qui
atteint deux tiers des jeunes parce que
les jeunes même si j'ai entendu ce qui a
été dit sur l'accoutumance à la
démocratie commencé un peu plus tôt mais
les jeunes au coeur de leur abstention
si forte réside une crise du résultat
c'est avant tout la crise du résultat
des jeunes sont très dans la promesse du
politique à la française c'est à dire
dans l'imaginaire du politique c'est à
dire je vous délègue mon vote et vous en
vous et lui voue représentant en échange
vous transformez vous changer la vie
vous peser sur le cours des choses et
c'est vrai que c'est ça qui est un tout
à fait au coeur de l'abstention convoi
les jeunes ne sont pas sur une logique
totalement à ce qu'on croit du tous
pourris visée lipolytique ils ont sur
une vie du tous impuissants notamment
vous avez parlé de l'éco anxiété
l'absence de solution sur la question
climatique c est frédéric lordon vous
interromps poche de parce que je
reprends un chiffre de votre
de votre enquête pour le livre la
fracture 80% des jeunes considèrent que
le personnel politique n'est pas honnête
il ya deux lectures dans ce mot ça peut
ramener au scandale et donc là ça serait
super c'est pas ça c'était les promesses
ne sont pas tous les atouts en forme
d'authenticité c'est une forme de
conformité entre les promesses et les
actes et d'ailleurs on va peut-être par
les mails macro obtient un score très
honorable à chez les plus jeunes 18 24
ans parce que la critique des promesses
non tenus à son égard contrairement à
françois hollande contrairement sur toi
nicolas sarkozy émerge peu dans le
discours des français général de
l'unesco déjeuner et pourtant mathieu
croissandeau si on prend des mesures un
peu phare du quinquennat des mânes mâcon
c'est est ce ce revenu d'engagement
genèse et on a parlé très longtemps
puisque finalement quoi il ya un peu peu
décevant par rapport au projet initial
qu'est ce qu'on dirait que c'était un
serpent de mer oui qu'il sait qui c'est
qui la gauche dont la rsa jeunes et des
mesures ont été mises en place s'appelle
la guerre anti jeunes et là on a
maintenant une troisième mouture qui est
la mouture mac ronen qui ne voulait pas
que ça s'appelle rsa jeunes est que ce
soir rsa et donc c'est pour ça qu'à
chaque fois le prix de la république et
free qui était droit qui s'il ya des
devoirs et que le cep à deux pas des
allocations à ne rien faire aux jeunes
un petit peu comme le revenu universel
qui avait défendu dans la précédente
campagne benoît hamon est un paradoxe
schéma qu'on sait c'est le présente plus
jeunes pour les jamais eu et c'est un
jeune qui fait vieux si j'ose dire il
n'a jamais vraiment revendiquer cette
carte il a impressionné plus tôt sur la
scène internationale au début parce que
toulouse et c'est un jeune président et
ça a joué sans doute dans son élection
2017 mais vraiment il parle comme on
parlait parfois dans les années 50 il a
hérité de deux gestes de références
littéraires qui sont absolument pas les
références littéraires de deux jeunes de
j'avais dires de son agent fille tous
les coups de gens se sait pas se plonger
dans la littérature y'a pas d'âge - mais
tous les âges de la littérature mais
voilà il a dit il a des réflexes qui ne
sont ne sont pas directement jallet puis
une deuxième phase on l'a vu à la fin de
la deuxième moitié du quinquennat ou là
il s'est mis à utiliser de plus en plus
de canaux d'expression jeunes avec la ce
se ce président qui dit carabistouilles
est capable de parler sur tik tok nous
de parler de faire venir alors c'est pas
lui c'est gabriel attal qui a fait venir
des youtube heures à l'assemblée où lui
a fait venir mcfly karito faire des
galipettes dans le jardin à l'elysée
donc on voit bien qu'il ya eu un
recentrage pour quand même viser sa
adressé en tout cas cette population là
dans la perspective des élections et
aussi parce qu'il est d'une forme de
fracture une partie de la jeunesse plus
militante plus engagés politiquement lui
reproche un côté d'avoir rogner les
libertés publiques que ce soit les
violences policières aujourd'hui jaune
que ce soit reut le rhône et les
libertés publiques pendant le la gestion
du co lead on lui a beaucoup reproché à
raison au début parce que franchement le
gouvernement c'est pas du tout penché
sur le cas des jeunes pendant six mois
les six premiers mois de la pandémie on
le pensait qu aux personnes âgées
fragiles personnes pensaient aux
étudiants seuls dans leur chambre
d'étudiant et et donc il a voulu se
réconcilier il faudrait demander à
frédéric des millions d'années
aujourd'hui mais est-ce que son image
est meilleur aujourd'hui chez les jeunes
qu'au début quels jeunes nous parlons du
côté des 18 24 ans sont un peu moins
sévère que vous ils sont parfois même
sur un effet manu parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment que ce président et s'inscrit
en distinction par rapport à l'ensemble
du champ politique et par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs par exemple sa fameuse
phrase traverser la rue pour trouver un
emploi ça a plu à 7 ce segment
générationnel j'hésite 24 ans il est
plutôt un niveau élevé en revanche chez
les 25 30 ans la génération qui est dans
une période plus compliquée de
transition d'insertion professionnelle
l'a clairement ses sagesses et ce sous
celle mangin jeunes qui volent très
fortement pour marine le pen et à il est
très fortement remonté notamment
également c'est la question que vous
parliez des libertés publiques et est
d'ailleurs puisque vous parliez de la
crise sanitaire de deux éléments là
encore puiser dans rendant dans la
fracture
crise que vit d avenir des jeunes 62 %
des jeunes ont peur de l'avenir et puis
ce sentiment d'avoir été sacrifié
68%
considère qu'il ya eu un sacrifice de la
jeunesse au profit des des plus âgés je
reste sur le le bilan des manuels macro
avec vous alexandre man sin aux
pourparlers des impacts mpack c'est une
start up politique et citoyenne qui
accompagne la mise en place de
politiques publiques innovantes est ce
que vous considérez que emmanuel macron
à innover dans sa politique envers la
jeunesse
oui alors je vais byron bay d'emtec dans
quelques instants je voulais simplement
dire que par rapport à la mesure par
rapport à la mesure du rabaissement de
de l'âge de vote à 16 ans est de faire
la jonction je pense que la jeunesse en
a marre aujourd'hui d'être d'être
instrumentalisés pour des pour des
considérations politiques
là je pense que le problème se situe
vraiment la tranche d'âge 18 24 ans on a
eu d'abstention qui est très
significative commençons d'abord à nous
interroger sur ce qui ne va pas dans
cette tranche d'âge pour ne pas lire et
répondre à des problèmes complexes par
départ des réponses simplistes c'est
normal parce que si on revient à chaque
fois sur les thèmes précédents en or n'y
arrivera pas votre bilan varie en
réalité il a été plutôt plutôt innovant
vous avez cité un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été faits qui ont été
prises pendant les crises le vide par
exemple un jeune une solution qui
consistait à accompagner précisément ces
jeunes en recherche d'emploi
avec des mesures de des politiques
publiques incitatives à l'angola
mythique fitial c'est assez intéressante
on peut également parler de tout là
l'innovation démocratique aussi qu'a eu
lieu avec le grand débat national qui a
fait suite avec fidji les jeunes ou
encore à la convention citoyenne et moi
le climat qui arrive est aussi considéré
comme une comme une innovation
démocratique assez significative donc
oui je pense en tout cas de mon point de
vue que
toutes ces mesures de démocratie
participative c'est ce qu'on promeut et
c'est ce qu'on défend à travers m acte
inquiète une plateforme qui consiste à
mettre en
faire le lien entre les élus d'un côté
et les administrés de l'autre et qui
consiste à régénérer un peu la
démocratie participative en permettant à
tous les citoyens de donner leur avis eh
bien oui nous pensons qu'à travers
toutes ces mesures qui ont été mises en
place par le parisien la république aux
producteurs de l'écrit sanitaires mais
aussi
faisant suite aux différentes et social
deck avec dédain on peut dire que à
certains égards le quinquennat a quand
même considérable non ils osaient dans
le conduit démocratique je suis pas sûr
que tous mes invités soient sur la même
ligne que vous mélanie vogel oui bon moi
ça me fait un peu rire de mentionner le
grand débat national comme étant une
innovation démocratique qui aurait
fonctionné on peut dire que c'était
innovants comme outil mais le problème
c'est que c'est un outil qui a pas
marché puisque à la suite du débat il
n'y a pas eu de réponse politique c'est
la même chose que la convention
citoyenne climat qui est une bonne chose
c'est une très bonne chose il faut le
refaire ça marche on met 140 pers 150
personnes a discuté pendant un an d'un
d'une question y répondent mais après
les chefs d'entreprise sont en train de
faire ça oui mais attention des chefs
d'entreprise pour le climat eh ben on
déçoit et c'est ça le problème donc bon
mais si on prend d'autres éléments dont
on parle et alexandre sino le un jeune
une solution par exemple ou même
l'apprentissage là sont des chiffres
l'apprentissage qui est en train de
progresser en france et c'est un vrai
levier pour l'emploi donc est ce que
vous pouvez quand même donné un
satisfecit même léger au quinquennat
mâcon sur ces thèmes-là non mais il faut
aussi vous ça vous fait plaisir mais ça
me ferait plaisir c'est pour savoir
comment je pense que le nous ce qu'on
défend par exemple c'est de sortir de
cette logique paternaliste on a des
droits des devoirs machin ce que défend
yannick jadot c'est la notion de revenu
citoyen qui est une condition de
ressources mais pas de ce qu'on fait
après et voilà je donc le fait que le
gouvernement ait refusé de mettre le rsa
pour les jeunes mais ça pour moi c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus important
que la question du droit de vote à 16
ans et on voit que quand grégory douce
et le fait à lyon le revenu de
solidarité jeunes ça marche et ça sort
des jeunes delà de la précarité c'est
beaucoup plus important de mettre au
point des solutions qui répondent à
leeuw vrai problème la précarité c'est
les jeunes ça existe il faut des
solutions pour en sortir et
je vous interromps parce que je vois que
le sans fil il reste une douzaine de
minutes et encore plein de thèmes
passionnants je reviens sur le sondage
on entend parler en début d'émission
sondage qui date d'il ya dix ans une
semaine mais qui avait été voilà le lait
les jeunes qui ont été sondées ont été
entendus quoi moi il ya un mois après
c'est ça bon marine le pen qui arrivent
en tête des intentions de vote 25%
est-ce que c'est lié à cette proposition
d'exonération d'impôt sur le revenu pour
le moins de 30 ans on écoute la
présidente du rassemblement national
pourquoi je fais cette proposition parce
que il y a énormément de nos jeunes qui
s'expatrient que c'est une perte de
substance pour notre pays que c'est une
perte pour notre économie que c'est une
perte de vitalité que c'est une perte de
richesse que c'est une perte de la
richesse du capital d'humains que
représente encore une fois c'est moins
de 30 ans que je veux garder en franc je
veux qu'ils y créer leur famille je veux
qu'ils y créer éventuellement leur
entreprise c'est la raison également
pour laquelle je propose une exonération
évidemment avec certaines conditions de
l'impôt sur les sociétés pour les
créateurs d'entreprises de moins de
trente ans durant cinq ans je veux qu'il
fasse profiter leur pays de leur talent
de leurs
films à peine qui n'est plus président
du rassemblement la foule parce que
c'est jordan dare n'est là depuis
qu'elle est officiellement
candidate d'exonérer d'impôt les sur les
revenus les jeunes moins de 30 ans et
qu'il ya même bape est qui qui va être
content évidemment mais au-delà de cette
boutade frédéric dabi est ce que c'est
un socle solide ça quand même parce que
ça peut sembler étonnant mais 25% des
jeunes qui disent voilà on votera
d'abord pour marine le pen c'est pas une
vraie surprise on se souvient que jean
marie le pen était par exemple arrivé
quasiment tête en 95 auprès des jeunes
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
lui il s'est diffusée dès les plus
jeunes quand marine le pen aussi bien en
2012 qu'en 2017 avec des scores un petit
peu inférieur à sa moyenne nationale je
n'ai plus jeune je le disais c'est chez
les 25 30 ans c'est une relation qui
sincèrement comme de la même manière par
symétrie elle fait des meilleurs scores
auprès des 50 64 ans qui une génération
qui souffrent beaucoup pour tunis et une
série de raisons comparé aux personnes
âgées dans ce qui est intéressant avec
cette proposition qui est assez forte
c'est à quel point même si on peut dire
tu es jeune sauvaitre ou les oubliés de
la présidentielle l'ensemble des
candidats ont proposé des mesures
spécifiques à l'égard des jeunes depuis
la création des reins rsa jeunes une
allocation d'autonomie pour les
étudiants le droit de vote à 16 ans on
l'a vu avec anne hidalgo pour certains
malgré tout même si numériquement c'est
un segment électoral qui pèsent peu qui
n'a jamais emporté une à une une
décision présidentielle en 2007 ségolène
royal arrive très demandés les jeunes au
premier et au second tour elle est
battue parce que des personnes plus
âgées on vote pour nicolas sarkozy
clairement les candidats et je pense que
le coville a été a eu un effet
amplificateur s'adresse quand même assez
fortement aux jeunes oui je suis
d'accord avec cet argument mais on a le
sentiment que cela n'imprime pas
forcément où ça donne pas le tempo que
ce n'est pas l'ailé les propositions qui
donne le plus beau c'est un peu de cette
campagne c'est sur ces prêts entrés en
campagne que ce que j'irais annuel ce
vote rassemblement national ou ceux où
ses intentions de votre rassemblement
national il ya les deux dans la
démonstration de frédéric dabi ça
rejoint ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est une autre forme de
protestations que l'abstentionnisme par
exemple ce qu'est ce que vous faites le
lien oui mais il faut quand même
j'ai rejoint ce que disait frédéric dabi
c'est à dire que c'était pas du tout
nouveau maintenant ça fait très
longtemps que le rassemblement national
ex front national a consolidé un socle
électoral au sein de la jeunesse on peut
on peut le déplorer mais effectivement
c'est une c'est une réalité parce que
derrière ce derrière ce parti ya pour
les jeunes qui sont les plus d'ailleurs
atteint par part justement de cette
situation
des conditions d'insertion sociale
professionnelle difficile dans notre
pays pour pour les jeunes les jeunes non
diplômés les jeunes effectivement qui
sont souvent
100-150 capacité d'autonomie eh bien ils
y trouvent dans ces parties dans ce
parti en particulier et bien voilà un
porte voix alors à leur souffrance un
porte voix pour se faire entendre
auxquels s'ajoute en plus le refus du
système politique la dénonciation des
élites voilà qu'elle se raccrochent
effectivement toute cette ce contexte de
défiance donc donc c'est pas c'est pas
nouveau mais n'oublions pas qu'il ya
effectivement
cette tentation on va dire pour pour
cette extrême que représente le
rassemblement national mais il ya aussi
la tentation aussi pour l'extrême gauche
ou pour des alternatives des
alternatives politiques plus radical
donc ya en tout cas chez les jeunes la
recherche d'autres choses la recherche
de solutions n'oublions pas on parle sur
ce plateau mais n'oublions pas que
maintenant les gouvernements successifs
les présidents de la république
successifs etc n'ont jamais vraiment
depuis une trentaine d'années trouver de
vraies réponses mis en place de vraies
solutions pour que les jeunes trouvent
leur place dans la société à la hauteur
effectivement de ce qu'ils peuvent
donner à cette société qu'ils y soient
reconnus
dans des bonnes conditions et qu'ils
aient accès à une autonomie adultes
important il ya quand même dans la
fracture des chiffres qui peuvent un peu
et nous étonner mathieu 47% approuverait
d'avoir la tête du pays un chef qui n'a
pas à se préoccuper du parlement et des
élections
34% à prouverait que l'armée dirige le
pays il ya une demande de radicalité de
ce centre jeunesse pour paraphraser ce
que ce que général michel quand vous
sentez pas de place dans le système vous
dit on va changer le système et c'est
quand on est à cet âge là et qu'on ne se
voit pas effectivement de perspectives
d'avenir qu'elles soient économiques
professionnels environnementale vous
disais et si on changeait tout et en ccs
et ça n'est pas neuf non plus sur cette
cette radicalité elle a toujours plus
plus tôt exister dans la jeunesse et
elle sert les deux pôles les plus
radicaux qui sont l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche après
jean-luc mélenchon par exemple est en
train de mener une campagne un peu
différente des autres c'était qu'il va
beaucoup au contact des jeunes surtout
les jeunes des étudiants dont il fait
beaucoup de tours c'est une à ma
connaissance luc seul candidat à faire
ça de façon méthodique là qu'il va à peu
près dans toutes les villes
universitaires et dans des milieux qui
ne sont pas forcément favorables il veut
notre école de commerce et/ou pour
adresser son discours et son programme
et et en débattre avec avec les jeunes
est ce que ce sera payant quand on
regarde les chiffres que que vous nous
proposez tout à l'heure pas forcément
mais après les mesures typique jeunes
elles sont aussi beaucoup parfois la
réchauffer parce que personne n'a trouvé
la bonne martingale pour alors il ya
c'est survenu peut-être qu'on peut qu'on
peut imaginer jean luc mélenchon par
exemple qui propose de refaire des
emplois jeunes étaient une quelque chose
qui a été fait par martine aubry
ministre de l'emploi ça doit être
et ce qui avait mis le pied à l'étrier
soit 10 a350 1000 jeunes en france et
quand on a un emploi on a des revenus
mais on a accès plus facilement un
logement c'est la base cela n'est donc
c'est peut-être une vieille mesure mais
c'est vrai que c'est l'insertion
professionnelle reste quand même au delà
du cannabis au delà du droit de vote à
16 ans ça reste à mes yeux la priorité
que demandent d'ailleurs les jeunes au
val ou autres éléments de votre enquête
il faut pour la fracture 72% près des
jeunes prêts à s'engager dans la lutte
contre le changement climatique mélanie
vogel
72% c'est un chiffre massif pourquoi ils
votent pas tous en europe ecologie les
verts kèkè et où quand comment ça se
fait que vous voyez ce que je veux dire
entre ce mouvement-là de fond qui semble
emporter la jeunesse et le poids
électoral potentiel d'un yannick jadot
pour l'instant évidemment dans cette
campagne plein jour merci de dire pour
l'instant non mais on voit quand même
que alors bien sûr on a les chiffres là
qui date d'il ya un mois aux dernières
élections européennes s'étaient yannick
jadot enfin les écologistes qui était le
premier parti des jeunes pour les
européennes parce que c'est une élection
et jean remis à ce que je disais au
début sur notre système politique en
france avec la vème république etc
système majoritaire qui construit un
débat public très binaire est divisée il
ya la majorité et qu'il ya trop de
pouvoir et qui fait des promesses
intenables et l'opposition qui n'a pas
de pouvoir et aussi pas de
responsabilité et du coup tout ça c'est
une machine à créer de la frustration je
pense que dans l'est dans les pays où on
à la proportionnelle on a des débats
politiques beaucoup plus intelligente
est beaucoup plus sain parce qu'en fait
on est tous obligés de travailler les
uns avec les autres au lendemain des
élections et on a plus l'impression que
notre vote c'est tout bête mais en fait
en france on est dans un système où pour
les législatives où pour la
présidentielle il y à des millions de
votes qui ne servent à rien en réalité
alors que quand on est dans un système
proportionnel c'est tout bête mais en
fait chaque vote compte et ça ça compte
énormément est ce que c'est vraiment
est-ce que ça va être utile d'aller
voter si vous savez qu'à la fin de toute
façon il ya un seul gagnant eh bien tous
les autres bulletins sont jetés donc ça
c'est et c'est non seulement le vote
mais après tout le débat public parce
que vous parlez pas du tout de la même
manière dans une élection quand vous
pensez que vous allez être soit le
gagnant absolue seul perdant total que
quand vous pensez que après vous allez
travailler les uns avec les autres qu'on
sera dé majorino ramène à notre premier
débat sur la coalition à l'allemande ça
oui vous l'avez écouté si vous étiez
déjà un peu dans nos coulisses alexandre
lancino cette idée de la proportionnelle
est ce que ça fait partie des
innovations politiques est ce qu'on peut
parler d'innovation non parce que ça a
déjà existé sur lesquels vous vous
réfléchissez vous travaillez oui tout à
fait on pense que 30% de proportionnelle
serait serait potentiellement
intéressant on pourrait permettre est-ce
que tout le corps social s est ce que
tout le tissu politique et sociale
puisse être représentée après faisant
attention parce qu'on est très bien vu
sur les quatrièmes un lélio les trades
habilite de la proportionnelle mais une
proportionnelle justement dosée si je
puis dire seraient potentiellement
intéressante et c'est ce que nous
proposons dans le rapport programme
présidentiel on soumet combi est en
train de soumettre aux candidats
maintenant un mot très rapide sur le la
mesure de de la fiscalité de marine le
pen que ce soit à l'extrême droite à
l'extrême gauche bon temps quand même à
à à mettre sur le mettre dans le débat
public à sa demande de proposition et
c'est assez réductrice et assez assez
démagogique le lait la baisse de la
fiscalité moi je rappelle simplement que
le lierre ppn touche moins d'un français
sur deux en 46 % si je ne m'abuse des
français sont assujettis à l'impôt sur
revenu sur le revers
faible quand même de deux jeunes
changeait pas les chiffons tête mais a
priori fin très très peu de jeunes
seraient concernés par cette mesure
d'une part et d'autre barre et là je
bats la remet avec ma casquette d'avocat
ça pose un problème ça poserait
potentiellement un problème d'ordre
constitutionnel par rapport au principe
d'égalité devant l'impôt par rapport à
l'unique critère de l'âge ça pourrait
potentiellement poser quelques quelques
difficultés donc je pense que le plus
important c'est d'innover j'irai dans
cette démocratie c'est de permettre
d'autres formes de démocratie
perspective d'émerger pour faire en
sorte et bien de que chacune et chacun
puisse se retrouver à travers de l'île à
travers l'école à travers l'éducation à
la citoyenneté qui doit se faire dès le
plus jeune âge à travers un examen
national d'entrée au collège qui
pourrait justement s'assurer que chacune
et chacun hectares et d'un niveau je
dirais
global suffisamment complet par rapport
à l'histoire de france rapport aux
valeurs par rapport à cette citoyenneté
c'est ce que nous proposons c'est ce que
nous défendons
dont nos propositions le tout avec ce 7
valeurs d'exigence un de nivellement
vers le haut on croit en la jeunesse
maison confiance en la jeunesse et c'est
précisément parce qu'une croyons en
cette jeunesse que l'exigence ne
d'obèses être bradés on doit on doit
agir en responsabilisant ans ils ont
besoin de vous intégrer et c'est la fin
de l'émission donc il faut que je vous
interromps je signale que vous avez
présidé en mars prochain avec le
sénateur de l'essonne vincent delahaye
un colloque au sénat sur ce thème de la
démocratie participative merci à tous
anne muxel rappel le titre de votre
livre c'est politiquement jeunes c'est
aux éditions de l'aube et frédéric dabi
avec stewart show la fracture publié aux
éditions les arènes merci à toutes et à
tous surtout faisait particulièrement
froid ce soir sur ce plateau d'on pas à
toutes nos excuses voilà il a fallu
tenir dans ce frigo et c'était
passionnant mais celle hausse et voilà
c'est resté chaleureuse mais bon c'était
pas ça merci à tout ça